bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe et
donc votre rendez vous de l'actualité
européenne des chaînes parlementaires
dans cette émission je vous emmène en
roumanie avec près de 15 millions
d'hectares de terres ce pays dispose de
la cinquième plus grande surface
agricole de l'union européenne est une
aubaine pour de nombreux agriculteurs et
investisseurs étrangers qui achètent des
terres arables alors faut-il se méfier
de la ruée vers les terres roumaines
nous en débattrons avec nos invités mais
d'abord l'actualité depuis quelques mois
les couloirs de bruxelles et de navarre
bruisse de rumeurs sur le futur traité
transatlantique dont les négociations se
déroulent à huis clos
alors ce tt ip et ils antidémocratique
c'est la question la semaine avec simon
barbarie
celles traitées qui fait peur le tt ip
le partenariat transatlantique de
commerce et d'investissement prévue pour
entrer en vigueur dès l'année prochaine
cet accord mettrait en place une
gigantesque zone de libre échange entre
les états unis et l'europe un marché de
820 millions de consommateurs ça en fait
du monde une véritable arme secrète pour
les états en mal de reprise économique
non mais alors pourquoi les négociations
entre la commission et washington sont
elles si discrète
rien ne filtre et compris pour les
députés européens pourtant représentants
du peuple
pour les opposants au traité les
négociations seraient carrément
illégitime avec le ppip les
réglementations entre l'amérique et le
vieux continent seraient harmonisés
mais par le bas on pourrait par exemple
voir débarquer en europe
un bon gros boeuf aux hormones américain
pire en cas de différend entre une
entreprise et un état c'est une durée
diction privé qui devra trancher
par exemple si une réglementation
nationale dérange une multinationale
la france pourrait se voir condamner
comme un vulgaire justiciables il faudra
y réfléchir à deux fois quand on votera
une loi alors le tti p1 accords anti
démocratique
alors ce traité transatlantique est il
véritablement antidémocratique ce karim
zéribi que je reçoive pour en parler
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe des verts et
vous êtes membre de la délégation avec
les états unis et la commission des
affaires étrangères
alors anti démocratique ou pas très
dangereux en tout cas pour l'europe ce
traité de libre échange que nous
combattons nous écologistes au parlement
européen nous avons fait partie des
députés qui ont voté contre l'ouverture
des négociations négociations qui ont
commencé en juin 2013 avec un mandat
donné à la commission mais dont on ne
sait plus grand chose aujourd'hui
à dire vrai et pour nous ça représente
un danger sur des enjeux
environnementaux d'abord en tant
qu'écologiste aussi alimentaires
agricoles les normes et les standards
sociaux et environnementaux européens
vont exploser pour se mettre au niveau
des européens on ne veut pas d'une
europe américanisé pour nous écologique
on vous dit que rien ne filtre il ya
pourtant huit députés qui sont censés
être associé en fait à cette négociation
vous ne discutait pas finalement avec
vos homologues nous discutons avec les
membres du congrès j'ai moi même été à
dublin puis à washington mais la
discussion ne contient pas des éléments
de fond est d'accord qui seuls
susceptibles d'être aujourd'hui passé
entre la commission et le commissaire
qui vient de passer à faire car le
groupe est sûrement le qu'américains à
un moment donné on va nous proposer de
qu'un accord de libre-échange ficelé
qu'il faudra effectivement validé au
parlement européen j'espère que le
parlement
le parlement mettra son veto car depuis
le traité de lisbonne tout accord de
libre échange doit être validé par le
parlement européen les parlementaires
heureusement la particularité c'est que
ce soit voulu valider en paquet soit
vous le valider en l'état soit vous le
il faut le refuser refuser cet accord de
libre échange je pense effectivement qui
nous tire vers le bas qui représente un
danger votre reportage est très bande de
ce point de vue les ogm le poulet
javellisée de que le boeuf aux hormones
tout ce qui faisait les normes
l'exigence environnementale de santé
alimentaire européenne va exploser pour
se mettre au niveau des amériques et
nous on vous le connaissez le mandat de
karel de gucht le commissaire européen a
obtenu ce mandat de la part du conseil
c'est à dire les états membres vous
savez ce qu'il ya dans ce
dans ce mandat n'est très flou ce mandat
il est très opaque on sait effectivement
qu'il y a quelques éléments que nous
avons souhaité au telle exception
culturelle de la france s'est beaucoup
battu et nécessite effectivement une
bataille nécessite une bataille de
co-conseil mais tout ce qui n'apparaît
pas dans les éléments de négociation
peuvent être discutés par ailleurs donc
par le commissaire en question très
franchement nouveau une boîte de pandore
qui met en danger à la fois les citoyens
les consommateurs européens sous
prétexte qu'on gagnerait quelques
centièmes de points alors justement on
nous annonce en fait des créations
d'emplois de la croissance
on en a peut-être besoin au moment où la
zone euro et a fortiori l'europe entière
à une croissance atone
on a besoin d'un développement on a
besoin de sortir de l'austérité on a
besoin de renforcer notre technique
solution marché de libre échange c'est
celui d'hier avec lui sans réponse à nos
problématiques d'emploi de chômage
d'inquiétude de nos colonnes la création
d'un livre récent j'avais 17 ans je ne
le crois qu'un marché de 820 millions à
l'heure où on à la chine d'un côté l'un
d'un milliard et demi un milliard de
l'autre côté droit que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est de renforcer un tissu
économique qui s'appelle les pme les pmi
c'est d'aller d'un champ de l'innovation
c'est d'aller vers l'économie verte
d'aller vers l'exigence environnementale
là effectivement nous avons des pistes
et des gisements d'emplois considérables
pour l'europe sans pour autant brader
tout ce à quoi nous tenons et nous avons
aujourd'hui fait monter en puissance des
standards sociaux environnementaux
il ne faut pas qu'ils explosent sous
l'égide de ce traité de libre échange il
ya un véritable danger
aujourd'hui il faut comprendre la
considération et à mesure alors il ya un
autre projet qui inquiète nos
concitoyens c'est cette histoire de
justice arbitrale
ça veut dire que en gros dans ce traité
enfin tout ça sont des supputations
serre que rien n'est acté aujourd'hui à
l'heure où l'on parle
la justice ne serait pas rendue par une
juridiction
qui seraient des juges mais par une
forme de justice arbitrale qui mettrait
les états au même titre que les
multinationales
donc on pourrait attaquer les états au
même titre qu'une multinationale donc de
marty exxon mobil attaque par exemple la
pologne en disant nous on veut exploiter
le gaz de schiste vous pourriez être
condamné c'est un traité qui va
favoriser les multinationales et leur
puissance est aussi effectivement où ça
va nous mener
vous parlez d'énergie le gaz de schiste
notamment ce traité permettra aux
multinationales d'aller au delà des
législations nationales et listes
nationales qui ont été lus par la
souveraineté nationale par les peuples
va être mise à mal
donc c'est un traité qui va nous mener
sur le chemin qui va être celui je
dirais de la mise à mal de la démocratie
à laquelle nous tenons de traité
antidémocratique traité qui favorise les
multinationales traité qui va favoriser
le business on va dire saint standards
environnementaux et sociaux aujourd'hui
et malouda the 605 schiste permettra à
une multinationale de venir je dirais
faire des forages en europe alors que
nous avons en gros vous êtes en train de
dire aux simpson mobile pourrait par
exemple devenir fort et en ile de france
dès juin nous on a obtenu le droit par
cette justice arbitrale sous l'égide de
ce traité on pourra mettre la france en
difficulté si celle ci refuse
effectivement d'ouvrir je dirais du
foncier du terrain disponible pour que
la la la l'exploitation du gaz de
schiste et nous considérons nous encore
une fois qu'ils seront pleines d'un âge
est considérable donc il faut
aujourd'hui que nous puissions tirer
l'europe vers le haut nos positions
envers l'eau que l'europe ne soit un
exemple qu'il y ait un modèle européen
alors ça le vrai défi qui se présente à
nous s'il me guérir de s'américaniser
vous nous parler de modèle européen
c'est assez drôle si je puis dire
sachant qu'on vient de sortir des
municipales actuellement en france vous
êtes de marseille karim zéribi et vous
avez depuis quelques jours un nouveau
maire dans le 7e secteur et je voudrais
qu'on les écoute
en gagnant ici eh bien nous pouvons
gagner la france
donc c'est une étape qui doit nous
conduire à terme à 2017
le rendez vous encore plus historique
que celui que nous venons de prendre ici
localement c'est 2017
et voilà c'est une une première marche
ou une étape vers cet vers cet objectif
karim zéribi la prochaine étape 2010 est
entre temps on a les européennes
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour contrer
le fn dans une ville comme marseille
il faut pas le diaboliser il faut
débattre avec lui sur le fond et il faut
effectivement prendre en considération
la désespérance de nos concitoyens et
puis ce qui favorise le front national
c'est l'abstention
lorsque l'abstention est forte
mécaniquement le front national est
aussi de qu'il faut faire en sorte de
recoller renouer la confiance entre nos
concitoyens le politique on étend des
infections forte moi j'ai fait campagne
à marseille pour les municipales les
marseillais et les français en général
n'y croit plus et donc ceux qui se
déplacent vers les urnes ont omis de
sanctionner de protester je dirais
d'exhorter un mal être il faut apporter
une réponse forte pour moi ces réponses
ne sont républicaines mais sont aussi
dans l'innovation
on ne peut plus faire de la politique
comme les partis traditionnels nous
propose de le faire de qu'il faut ouvrir
une nouvelle ère et le front national
apparaît aujourd'hui c'était c'est un
comble comme le parti j'ai envie de dire
un peu décomplexée de la rénovation
c'est catastrophique d'imaginer ça mais
quand on voit des mers front national
compte 30 en 35 ans
et quand on voit effectivement des gens
s'accrocher à leur mandat 70 75 ans à
l'ump ou au ps ait pas effectivement
qu'il faut s'interroger sur le
renouvellement du personnel politique
sur une authenticité retrouver en
politique sur un discours vrai et puis
surtout sur des réponses qui sont de
réponse républicaine laïque forte où
tout un chacun pourra se retrouver le
front national c'est la division
c'est le roger c'est la n2 on le sait
maintenant il faut l'attaquer sur le
fond quel projet gravier et moi nous
montrer ce qui va être capable de faire
à l'envers la mairie du 7e secteur de
force
karim zéribi on annonce 23%
potentiellement dans les sondages pour
le comme marine le pen lors des
prochaines européennes
comment on fait quand un parlement
européen
peut-être d'ici juillet aura un groupe
politique qui représentera peut-être 25%
d'abord d'ici là faut faire campagne et
européen convaincu comme le nom
écologistes ils faut
indiqué que ne sommes pas des européens
nous voulons réorienter l'europe la
réajuster changer l'europe
mais changer l'europe et du fédéralisme
ce que l'on changé l'europe pour faire
en sorte que l'europe encore une fois
c'est une europe n'ont pas de
l'austérité mais des investissements
d'avenir de la jeunesse de l'emploi de
la solidarité
doc septembre plat est apparu très
libérale de que plutôt favorable aux
multinationales aux grands acteurs
économiques à la finance est
effectivement temps qu'on aura cet finir
avec leur démarche et tant qu'on aura
cette europe là nous côtoyer n'y
croiront pas et voudront et auront la
tentation du repli de l'euro scepticisme
qui est porté par le front national dont
il faut faire campagne pour une europe
du changement une réorientation de
donner vie à l'ombre en indiquait
effectivement qu'il ya des combats à
mener
et puis effectivement ensuite il va
falloir batailler au sein du parlement
européen parce que si on a des
eurosceptiques le chemin pour faire
avancer l'europe va être plus difficile
il faut que nos concitoyens l'entendent
il faut mettre je crois en place au
parlement européen des eurodéputés de
combat favorable à une oreille
solidarité c'est effectivement voilà moi
dans ce moment merci beaucoup karim
zéribi d'avoir été avec nous
nous on continue direction la roumanie
peut-être le futur grenier l'europe ce
qui l'a été dans l'entre-deux-guerres
depuis quelques années de nombreux
investisseurs et agriculteurs achètent
des terres arables là-bas pour investir
un véritable eldorado mais certains y
voient déjà un accaparement des terres
décryptage par marie brévaux et mehdi
chebana
dans la famille de denis thomas on est
viticulteur de père en fils depuis plus
de dix générations en plein coeur de la
bourgogne à nuits saint georges
alors je vous emmène dans l'ignoble donc
sur les coteaux et quatre cinquièmes de
nos vignes quand en 1995 le domaine
familial est vendu ce passionné sa femme
font leurs valises direction sahara
athènes un petit village à 150 km de
bucarest
je suis venu en roumanie
attiré par le pinot noir bon être
bourguignon c'est mon cépages de
prédilection et je cherchais pour
l'entreprise familiale que je dirigeais
à développer les pinots noirs de qualité
l'orientation l'amplitude thermique des
terrains calcaires et haïr et toutes les
conditions ici sont réunis pour un
terroir d'exception
mais si denis thomas s'est exilé c'est
surtout qu'en roumanie les terres
agricoles représentent encore de belles
opportunités l'hectare ici est 20 fois
moins cher que dans sa région natale mai
2000 euros lecteurs pour de la terre non
plantés et 5000 pour des vignes plantées
en bon état 5 à 10 milles pour des
vignes plantées en bon état en bourgogne
c'est on commence à 60 milles pour finir
à 1 million d'hectares
le français est désormais à la tête d'un
domaine viticole de 70 hectares le fruit
de quinze ans d'investissement si denis
doit faire face à beaucoup de
tracasseries administratives
l'accueil des roumains l'a conforté dans
sa nouvelle vie dix salariés travaillent
à plein temps sur le domaine bonjour
bonjour tout mon respect qu'est ce que
vous faites
on laboure la saison a commencé ici le
regard porté sur les propriétaires
terriens étrangers et bienveillant et
surtout pragmatique
c'est une bonne chose qu'il vienne ici
et qu'ils fassent des affaires plutôt
que ça reste en l'état
c'est une bonne chose j'ai un avis
plutôt positif
s'il n'était pas venu peut-être qu'on
travaillerait plus être propriétaire
c'est un rêve
moi j'ai une propriété j'ai un hectare
de vigne c'est suffisant pour nicolas et
exploiter la terre pour son propre
compte et une lointaine chimère
comme pour beaucoup de paysan roumain
70% des terres reste consacré à une
agriculture de subsistance une
agriculture familiale à la mairie de
sare athènes
la ruée des fermes les occidentaux est
perçu comme une opportunité l'occasion
de moderniser une agriculture souvent
archaïques dans la région 30 % des
exploitations agricoles sont détenus par
des européens
à 28 ans votre adresse on apprend
beaucoup auprès des étrangers
une association avec les étrangers a
toujours apporté de bonnes choses en
fait il ne travaille pas vraiment ils
ont apporté les machines les outils et
ce sont les habitants de la commune et
de la région qui travaillent pour eux
physiquement il n'y a aucun chiffre
officiel mais on estime que 10 % des
terres arables en roumanie seraient
détenus par des étrangers principalement
des européens depuis quelques années des
voix s'élèvent et dénonce un
accaparement du sol roumain avec
l'entrée du pays dans l'union européenne
et la libéralisation du marché foncier
il est bien plus facile d'acheter des
terres agricoles pour les investisseurs
étrangers
pour l'une des plus importantes
fédérations de syndicats agricoles
le problème est ailleurs loin s'en faut
que je travaille sur ce dossier
des collègues en ont besoin il faut que
je passe les voir la taille des
exploitations pour la plupart des mini
parcelle distribuer à la révolution
roumaine ne sont pas à la hauteur du
marché européen
la seule solution c'est l'association le
remembrement
c'est la seule solution qui permettrait
de sortir du marasme
car s'associer ça donne la possibilité
de mieux capitaliser les subventions la
possibilité de courir le crédit de la
banque car la surface est plus grande
mais s'associer c'est surtout la
possibilité de vendre la production à un
prix bien plus avantageux la puissance
de négociation des paysans grandi depuis
bruxelles a accordé près de 10 milliards
d'euros à la roumanie exclusivement pour
l'agriculture et le développement rural
67 % de cette somme a déjà été utilisé
mais les petits paysans et les petites
exploitations roumaines ont toujours de
très grandes difficultés à accéder à ces
fonds
alors la roumanie deviendra-t-elle la
troisième puissance agricole d'europe je
reçois des députés européens sur ce
plateau pour en parler cristian dan
preda bonjour vous êtes député européen
orge romain membre du parti populaire
européen et marc tarabella on ne vous
présente plus vous êtes député belge
socialistes et démocrates
cristian dan preda je me tourne vers
vous il y avait énormément de polémique
autour de cette question d'achat de
terres arables par des européens de
l'ouest voire par des étrangers
extra-européens
est-ce que vous parlez ici
d'accaparement de terres arables ou est
ce que c'est une opportunité pour la
roumanie
non c'est une excellente opportunité
donc nos frères européens ont déjà
profité il faut dire que quelques 800
mille hectares sur les 14 17 millions de
hectares terres arables je veux dire
sont déjà détenues par des italiens des
allemands des anglais des espagnols les
suisses si ils sont là il ya aussi
quelques 10 % de cette aide-là qui sont
détenus par des gens venant des pays
arabes et cela était possible même avant
cette libéralisation complète de 1er
janvier 2014
parce qu'il ya eu des achats par des
sociétés et donc comme dans vos des
portages dans le domaine du vignoble
dans différentes cultures agricoles
on en a profité c'est pour le bien du
pays cet excellent et ça doit continuer
vous êtes d'accord marc tarabella il n'y
a pas une part en fait de privatisation
six étudiants des terres arables
roumaine je suis partiellement d'accord
et qui vient dire c'est vrai que
l'agriculture roumaine à vocation et la
roumanie à vocation devenir un des plus
grands producteurs agricoles européens
il que ça saigne l europe dans
l'entre-deux-guerres et est l'idée c'est
d'y revenir
il ya beaucoup de terre de qualité un
climat exceptionnel qui sont
sous-exploitées c'est vrai mais la plus
grande partie de la population rurale
vit de l'agriculture
alors c'est vrai que c'est une
agriculture de subsistance qui permet
quand même aux gens de se nourrir alors
c'est vrai qu'ils vivent dans des
conditions précaires très souvent et
qu'on a envie d'un développement ma
crainte à moi je le dis clairement c'est
que la transition agricole qu'on a vécu
au niveau de différents pays européens
comme la france la belgique ou
aujourd'hui
on est à 1 ou 2 ou 3% de la population
active qui vit de l'agriculture par
rapport à 30 ou 40 % pour les romains
oui mais nous avions nous avons vécu ça
aussi dans l'avant guerre chez nous la
même proportion la population et est
impliqué dans l'agriculture non
contraignant n'ait transition h et rien
qui rend this y ont beaucoup trop rapide
et qu'il va devenir la population rurale
ici le viticulteur à 70 hectares il fait
travailler dix personnes j'ai vu des
fermes en roumanie 2-3 4000 hectares qui
fonctionne avec cinq six tracteurs donc
cinq six emplois temps plein et donc je
me dis que s'il ya un accaparement des
terres
c'est quand même au détriment de petites
surfaces d'agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui
produisent pour se nourrir et c'est vrai
ne développe pas malheureusement
l'activité économique qui le
mériteraient de développer mais si on va
d'une transition d'une petite
agriculture de subsistance directement
vers une agriculture hyper productiviste
il y aura peut-être que certaines zones
montagneuses où les petits agriculteurs
vont pouvoir se maintenir voire
développer leurs activités car ils le
mériteraient de commercialiser leurs
produits et on parle directement ici du
marché européen
attention il ya aussi la demande
intérieure et je crois qu'à la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important
et donc ma crainte que va devenir
l'essentiel de la paysannerie roumaine
dans les années à venir sachant que les
terres vont être effectivement prise est
accaparé par des fermes de plus en plus
grosse et qui vont être porteuse de
moins en moins d'emplois alors que c'est
justement est ce qu'il faut craindre une
forme de transition trop rapide vers une
agriculture je dirais de marché qui
derrière va coûter aussi de l'emploi
non je crois que achement là il ya un
certain équilibre entre
les petites exploitations et les grandes
rit encore presque 40% des gens qui
vivent de l'agriculture et pour le
paysan roumain s'est quand même vu le
niveau moyen de vie une chance
extraordinaire il faut savoir que la
subvention payer pour un hectare en
roumanie 7 au niveau de l'année 2013
dans les quelque 140 euros et ça va
augmenter jusqu'en 2019 jusqu'à 190 oui
mais ces exemples sicile il s'agit en
fait de donner ces subventions si je
puis dire à des étrangers pour exploiter
les terres roumaines est-ce qu'il ya pas
un hiatus là non parce que quand je
disais il n'y a pas dans l'est dans les
années qui nous ont précédés et c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
je vais en devenir il n'y a pas un
accaparement comme vous avez dit on a
beaucoup discuté juste avant le 1er
janvier ce moement 2014 sur le manque de
libéralisation complète danger comme
quoi il y aura une sorte d' invasion oui
j'ai d'ailleurs été à monsieur manipulés
par des mouvements nationalistes en
voilà et c'est pas le cas on est
anne avril et le prix n'a pas bougé par
rapport à l'automne passé il n'y a pas
eu des ventes exceptionnelles
au contraire il ya une sorte de gel
maintenant parce que beaucoup de gens ne
veulent pas vendre parce qu'ils
attendent depuis plus élevés et donc
pour l'instant on est très loin de cette
invasion
j'étais plutôt une opportunité
d'importer des savoir faire et des
outils et puis de l'histoire grandiose
et de faire entrer les paysans les
fermiers roumain sur la marché avec un
peu plus de courage et avec un peu plus
de chance parce que jusqu'ici c'est vrai
vu le fait que la roumanie est entré
très tôt en 2007 et vu cette période
deux blocs de blocage sur la
libéralisation de l'achat des terres on
était quand même marginalisée ou avant
2007 bien sûr absent et donc ça va nous
donner une chance importante et je crois
que il faut regarder simple toit avec
optimisme on est au début d'une belle
histoire et non pas à la fin d'une d'une
histoire de cauchemar
justement marc tarabella on est
peut-être au début effectivement d'une
belle histoire
est ce qu'il ne faut pas garder
confiance dans la capacité aussi du
peuple roumain et de ses dirigeants à
créer une forme de marché intérieur
européen et à offrir en fait cette
capacité de développement l'agriculture
roumaine sachant qu on risque d'être en
concurrence avec que ce soit le brésil
la chine l'inde
en ce qui concerne le besoin de matières
premières est ce qu'on n'a pas besoin de
ce grenier et de créer ce marché
intérieur agricole avec la roumanie en
troisième poste très clairement comment
on fait référence au brésil à les
acteurs extérieurs comme les etats-unis
ou desquels on importe massivement le
soja pour nourrir notre bétail très
clairement on doit avoir une stratégie
européenne d'essayer de diminuer notre
dépendance à l'égard d'autres continents
notamment du continent américain par
rapport à la production de protéines
végétales et c'est vrai que la roumanie
peut il contribuer largement mais aussi
nos voisins font parler d'eux
de l'ukraine ya pas tellement longtemps
oui très clairement oui mais il ya
d'autres problèmes mais bon c'est très
bien mais je reste quand même dubitatif
par rapport à cette hyper évolution qui
va aller très vite et qui va peut-être
laissé sur le bord du chemin une partie
la paysannerie roumaine moi je dirais
que
c'est pas la vitesse de la consommation
qu'on doit attendre c'est la lecture que
fait mon collègue bunge c'est justement
le contraire une lenteur parce que
on est depuis 2007 quand même un membre
de l'union européenne et les paysans
sont la catégorie sociale qui attend le
cuir et qui disent comme monsieur dans
le reportage et qu'elle a la vitesse
n'est pas trop trop accéléré qui n'a pas
tout pacsé les attendait beaucoup de la
politique agricole chez lui il faut 2
aux gens parce que nous sommes tous
européens on n'est pas des étrangers 1
par rapport à l'europe on est tous égaux
et donc moi je fais un appel à ce que
les gens viennent armani la terre et bon
marché très bon marché encore et donc on
a des paysans qui n'attend que
s'impliquer s'investir dans ce grand de
marchés européens alors mais comment
permettre aux agriculteurs roumain de se
constituer des parcelles on voit que la
problématique aussi c'est le
morcellement de la terre oui il commença
fin cela pourquoi parce que écoutez il
ya eu un vrai drame au début des années
90 parce qu'au moment de la restitution
de terres il y avait en quelque sorte le
le le drame de la du communisme et deux
associations forcer à les coopératives
agricoles de production qu avait inventé
le communisme et qui était une sorte de
deux d'associations forcé alors ils
hantent mis du temps pour s'habituer à
l'idée que l'association s'est pas
simplement la force la domination d'une
autorité d'atik mais cochet l'expression
de la libre volonté et donc depuis
quelques années chantante injustement de
reconstituer ce tissu associatif de se
mobiliser aussi voilà et pour travailler
ensemble pour l'échangé des expériences
et tours avant vraiment une force de
vent devant les autorités publiques
parce que autrement la tel était mon
seul et c'est qu'on a restitué les temps
enfin c'était un acte de juger ces
gens-là condition sinequanone pour
réussir en fait à exister dans un marché
européen
c'est une équation simple pour conclure
c'est vrai qu'à le pif et remis avec un
hectare en roumanie mais imaginons qu'il
grossisse ils s'associent pour acheter
du matériel et produire mieux et plus
très bien mais je préfère 3000 hectares
où vivent 100 familles sur chacune 30
hectares de 3000 hectares ou même
propriétaire qui lui va hyper s'enrichir
et qui va faire vivre dix travailleurs
qui vont conduire le tracteur
dernière question messieurs très
rapidement on voit que c'est aussi
l'eldorado de l'agriculture bio la
roumanie est ce que ce sont les mêmes
standards qu'en europe de l'ouest
est ce que le bio roumain est le même
que le bio français que le bio allemand
marc tarabella
oui le bio
au gré d'un charte éthique partout en
europe doit s'appliquer partout de la
même manière et c'est vrai qu'à côté la
culture hyper productiviste doit aussi
en roumanie coexister d'agriculture
vraiment de qualité car ils ont des
produits de qualité il n'est en train de
valoriser de commercialiser partout en
europe
la tomate roumaine est bien plus
savoureuse que la tomate andalousie
vous êtes d'accord que les étrangers
jeudi des autres pays européens et non
européens qui viennent chez nous disent
ce qu'ils disent sur la tomate sur nos
légumes sur novion dedans donc c'est
vraiment du vieux bio supérieurs aux
attentes
écoutez on vous invite tous à aller
manger de la tomate roumaine et la vigne
bio merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir
participé à ce débat avec nous c'est
terminé pour cette semaine rendez vous
la semaine prochaine à strasbourg avec
ahmed tazir bonne suite de programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires à bientôt